alex simon is the man behind
zero to epic a movement to promote
electric scooters and bikes as an
alternative to cars for short trips
why does it take you know an suv to move
a person for a mile or two
so micro micromobiles provide the
solution
to raise awareness next month simon will
embark on a 30-day
3 thousand plus mile journey from boston
to the oregon coast
all on his electric scooter i'll be
riding about 150 miles a day on average
give or take and that's about eight
hours a day on a scooter
over time simon says many will have to
use electric transportation out of
necessity
there are more people moving into cities
so in the next decade or so you're going
to see a lot more traffic
a lot more congestion a lot more
pollution a lot more noise
some local businesses are noticing this
trend already
here at southwest bikes clean commuting
is growing in popularity with three of
these e-bikes being sold in the last
week alone when we first started doing
it we weren't sure if it was going to
be popular or not but it's really
exceeded our expectations
rocky height is the owner of southwest
bikes near 95 and centennial parkway in
the northwest valley
he thinks e-bikes will be the fastest
growing segment of his store
e-commuter bikes are not that expensive
and you can put racks and haul anything
you want on them nowadays
both height and simon agree the next
step is for more cities to provide
infrastructure so people can e-bike
skate and scoot safely kate houston 8
news now